my head look it's a watch house kind of
put it okay we ready all right hey I was
going bros my name is beef fat I'm here
with country jiggy what put kicked
kicked PJ how long kick him
how long have we been friends feelings
too long not long enough
PJ I got a game for you oh all right are
you ready I'm so ready
How well do you know it doesn't involve
anime cuz I hate anyway what's the game
I got this toad oh not we got the UH the
anime test the anime to animate s can
you guess what the anime subtitle or
manga is saying it's not rhetorical
question no that's the game
oh okay that game that's the game if you
win you get to tattoo me again Oh tattoo
round two okay if you lose okay I know
you're not gonna like this you have to
touch toad make me slip you the tape
yeah slip you tied you have to touch him
okay all right okay all right all right
all right let the games begin
[Music]
you guys at home can play a long way
it's the PJ mr. Felix
first one there's a subtitle here I
photoshopped it too well but what is
that what is the cow saying wait what
what is the cow saying he's already
saying Moo mer Merc
we'll see what that is correct PJ damage
you you're good at this
thank you I can tell you've watched a
lot of a I've seen a lot of anime I
especially any animes with a cow in it
I'm very familiar with this of course
which anime is it cow Ball Z cabals
attack on Kelton it's an OVA it's a
really good episode you should watch it
next one okay yep I'm I don't even know
what this one is
I like how we've gone from really tame
cow to eatin but just eating some but
Felix what have you been watching uh
this is really good anime it's got a
really good yeah it looks good you see I
Photoshop the way that really well
mmm-hmm what is he saying what's in the
but I'm satisfied yeah yep I'm sad I'm
sad it's fine yeah I'm an idiot
damn it how was I supposed to know that
it you're not doing too well
one out two that's not too bad is it
what is this one saying
how the [ __ ] am I supposed to know this
guys is not saying anything it's mouth
isn't moving um that is correct PJ there
was no one yeah you're throwing in
curveballs and trick questions what's
the matter with you this is my game it's
like Jesus you're I just really like the
picture yeah it's a good picture
next one we got the next one no I mean
like a but today lots of busk oh no
that's a head in it that's definitely
that's a head in a bar he photoshopped
out the ass crack no no no okay this is
just the way I wouldn't do that to you
Peter
thank you I learn what I like to see
well yeah uncensored ass crack um what
are they saying she samples deep on
balls-deep what huh Felix please uh
please uh next one okay this one is a
little trickier a piece of my mm-hmm
just shut out of my wiener um all right
think what shoes out of wieners what is
this ah a piece of my come on PJ I know
you can do it I know you know a lot of
animates I didn't do I was shooting on
the Weiner I mean oh is this like a
little bird thing piece of my brain what
how did I know that cuz you've read it
PJ you just got busted no matter how did
I know that piece away can we actually
just reassess a piece of my brain just
shot at my wiener how did you guess that
PJ maybe you wrote this manga I knew
that it was you all along how did you
know Romeo moto that is me
that's my alternate anyway what's next
big lips don't have flop flop how could
you know wait what was your hands are
saying get it piglets don't have ah what
do they don't have think PJ what don't
pick words don't piglets have and to
work backwards what do they have they
have orgasms
they have hey guys welcome to the Peter
pear show I'm PG pi and I'm going to
okay uh listen we have a lot of them PJ
I need you to keep a faster Pryor they
don't have hands
I don't know are you [ __ ] kidding me
what are you [ __ ] kidding me
what then [ __ ] PJ I'm uh I am just go I
am Here I am the cat I am the animate
God you how did you do that you answer
to me that's freaky I'm a little weirded
AI didn't know you guys they I mean it's
now it's now routing is she pulling
balls out of his head she pulling balls
like a man's balls
as you do PJ alright yours is something
as you soft time oh it's close not
really I think I get that a soft and
tiny kind of similar I think I'm running
out of disk space give me one second why
did you why did you SWAT start sweating
so much as soon as this picture can
that's it what does monster do
it's okay here we go here we go I really
like this one so what I'm on I'm on my
favorite is this uh is this uh what I
mean he's gesturing to the butterfly
this is a butterfly is this a pigeon how
could you not get that hot PJ it's cuz I
thought you liked anime maybe maybe it's
good maybe it's got the wrong
prescription only whose class maybe or
maybe he's just a [ __ ] dumbass is
this a pigeon it could be no one stop
onii-chan I'm going to poop I mean while
she get it
fart close enough it's not close enough
pooping her father wait wait are these
feelings should he get a point for that
can you not [ __ ] harass do you think
I should get a point for that yeah oh
yeah
boxes and barrels oh [ __ ] huh but I
bought you for simulator you know comes
out in six days put I'm put oh [ __ ] I'm
stuck I'm okay this is one also one of
my favorites okay and this is from code
gasp I would recommend this one is
really really good I'll now proceed to
something myself with this fish Wow I
mean what do you do with the fish PJ you
tell me what you first think I'm gonna
pleasure myself with this fish you're
kidding if that's that's not no no okay
I feed myself with this it is pleasure
yourself what that [ __ ] [ __ ] this way to
[ __ ] me you recommended today you record
if it you do it you do it with him now I
don't even care
you reckon camping game Felix rec of
this game I have ever played I hate you
I'm put apart everybody subscribed to
kick the page a great times great
countin oh don't recommend your shitty
child don't recommend your weird animes
what was that code guess it's a great
anime hmm everybody splash he ever
pleasure yourself with a fish let's not
get into details okay oh I am legit
weirded out by this but yeah I hope you
all enjoyed watching at home that's not
the end no that is definitely a
definitely ending it doesn't there uh no
it was over before thank you someone
who's watching and even those are for
fair right come on
don't do anything here I have a meeting
later all right well a school man yeah I
mean you've got lots of tattoos on your
arm I'll just add to that okay
how about here should I want to risk it
risk that's it okay I mean I'll give you
a good one all right all right let me
let me get a good one first come on PJ
now don't do anything bad PJ I won't do
anything bad you can trust me I have
enough bed tattoos PJ oh yeah I know
this might hurt because it tattoo is it
moon main my favorite enemy good point
if you have drawn some hentai on your
own you did please don't let it be a
penis they won't trust me dude this is
not a penis I will not do that's okay
well no but see there no penises no buzz
I promise nearly the tension is killing
almost it's killing me I don't want all
right you can look now
I'm so proud you [ __ ] [ __ ] what
what what is this an accurate
representation of your career I can't
show these on YouTube the video is gonna
get censored now no way oh I'll make
sure that they work they won't censor
this one wait I need to opt PI's career
that's that's real clever I think that
might be your best tattoo yeah I think
I'm gonna get this one inked in yeah get
that inked and colored I think well
thank you so much Peter for coming alone
thanks for fighting Oh always a pleasure
I had a great time I had agree really
glad we yeah you're never coming up get
it now I'd love to every time I come on
I want to different I wanted to face
your body in some way can I try do this
one as well
chin up dick button okay we're just
gonna end it now check out PJ we did a
what did we do we did cringe foo and
Peter's channel check that out leave a
like for more likes and as always stay
awesome bros stay awesome be
[Music]